>>Rishi Chandra: Like Ambarish mentioned,
this has huge potential for you.
Right?
Because if you look at it, traditionally,
the living room and the entire TV ecosystem
has been closed, fragmented, and totally inaccessible.
You've never had a chance to really engage
with those users spending five hours a day
in front of this device.
Well, today, that can change.
Our goal with Google TV is to create an entire
new category of devices that are built around
openness, open for users to go wherever they
want on the open Web.
Open for developers to create new applications
specifically targeted for the living room.
And open to content owners to create new experiences
around their existing content and new ways
to distribute it.
Your TV just got a lot smarter.
And our goal is to have the same impact on
the TV experience that the smartphone had
on the mobile experience.
But, of course, we can't do this alone.
We need the help of the entire TV ecosystem
to take the platform and push it forward.
Whether it be a manufacturer, an operator,
distributor, or more.
And the only way to do that is if we are open
as well.
So I'm also happy to announce that what you
saw today, the Google TV platform, will be
open sourced into both the Android and Chrome
source trees.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Okay.
So now we've talked a lot about the platform
and the product.
So one major question is still left.
How is this coming to market?
Well, I'm happy to say, we're coming in a
big way.
'Cause we've partnered with some of the world's
leading consumer electronics brands, as well
as those leading the TV ecosystem, to deliver
three Google TV devices.
The first is from a company you may have heard
of, called Sony.
One of the leading innovators --
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Thank you.
-- one of the leading innovators in consumer
electronics and on the television itself.
They will be launching a full line of integrated
TVs and integrated Blu-ray player.
Second is from Logitech, another innovating
company for living room technology.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: They will be launching a
companion box which allows you to easily integrate
Google TV within your existing setup.
And the great thing is they're going to be
creating an entire new set of peripherals
around Google TV.
So you can even take the experience we showed
you today and even go further.
And then for the chipset, we've partnered
with Intel.
Intel will be powering all three of these
devices with their Intel Atom processor, which
can allow us to have a great experience across
TV and Web.
And it's coming in fall 2010.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: This is going to be an exciting
year.
But there's more.
We've also partnered with DISH Network.
We've actually been working with DISH for
several months on this platform to really
get the user experience right.
And we're actually working on an enhanced
Google TV experience using the IP control
protocol that Vincent actually mentioned earlier.
So DISH subscribers will be able to seamlessly
integrate their DVR and DOD content into the
Google TV experience.
And then, finally, we need a way to get it
into your hands.
So we've partnered with Best Buy, the nation's
leading consumer electronics company, to get
these products directly into your hands in
an easy way.
All right.
So what's the time line for developers?
Well, like Ambarish mentioned, today, you
can start take your existing sites and enhancing
them for the TV experience, even right out
of the box.
Early 2011, we'll be launching the Android
Market with an over-the-air update, as well
as Google TV SDK and TV Web API, so we can
actually do a lot of the integration you saw
today.
And then, finally, summer 2011, we will open
source the platform into the Android and Chrome
source trees.
This is an incredibly exciting time for users,
for developers, for everyone in the TV ecosystem.
By taking the best of what TV has to offer
today and the best of what the Web has to
offer today, we can create an entirely new
entertainment experience, one that's built
on openness, and we can enable new forms of
innovation in the living room we've never
seen before.